I asked him,
uh,
they asked me to get him on and I was like,
Eh,
I think I'm going to duck to that one.
But he's fucking eccentric and crazy.
He's alone and,
and so's this Randy and they,
they,
they've known each other forever.
And are they friends while they were real till all this shit started and,
oh,
it's fucking classic Randy.
It goes radical left.
He used to do,
he did a comedy album years ago.
It was him and a bunch of other guys and it was all,
it was all political.
It was like five guys or three a few guys.
I forget how many guy think Crimmins was on it.
Oh sure.
It's critical.
And uh,
maybe Jimmy tingle.
Yup.
Yeah.
And they had like a whole thing they were doing almost like a,
like a tour,
you know,
like super left wing,
politically aware.
But this is fucking way back in the day.
I want to say this is the 90s they were doing this.
No,
I mean he was,
he was,
he was always funny.
I mean,
I've watched him die every night at the,
uh,
catch rising stock cause he's hit me up to doing such inside political shit.
He'd be talking about a bill that was passed that day on the floor or whatever
the fuck and the crowd would be staring at him and he had a hot Asian girlfriend
and he'd be dying up there.
This is what I fell in love with them and he goes,
he goes,
that's my girlfriend over there.
I taught her a forwards and English,
not you crowd suck.
I mean he was really fucking funny but so political and inside and accent.
But he stayed at my apartment when I lived out here in la and he fucking like
tried to pick up my wife after I left.
I had to go on the road somewhere,
but I still love him.
He's fucking crazy.
But he,
he sent me a picture of him,
uh,
2016 in front of the embassy in London where,
what's his name was held up aside.
Really?
Yes.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
What's he doing out there?
And then all that shit came out about wikileaks and stuff.
So they thought he might've been the intermediary.
Yeah.
So he's gone in front of Roger Stone.
He's gone in front of model or a couple of times and,
and uh,
so there it is right here.
Who is Randy credico don't threaten to take away apartment associates dog if he
cooperated with Russia.
Investigate what he threatened to take away his dog.
Oh,
fucking you gotta read the texts that Roger Stone.
They're public.
I think what's sent to Randy.
I'm going to take your dog.
Oh yeah.
He goes,
let's get it on.
Beat the pred to die.
Oh,
I'm going to take you a fucking,
that's why I love this guy.
This guy had a Nixon Tattoo when he was 18 on his back.
Well,
I just don't do it as he marched in the gay parade in New York.
I fucking love him.
He's nuts.
Why do you in the getting crazy pro gay rights?
He's pro just,
yeah.
You know,
so he's just all over the place.
He's all over the place,
but he's a right,
I mean,
he had a Nixon Tac toe.
It's a fucking right wing.
But,
uh,
all the right wing people to get look at this look,
that is so ridiculous.
The fucking next,
that's a good tattoo too.
I know guys,
60 something years old at least.
And He loved my radio show on Sirius and,
and he,
uh,
he did,
he hosted info was,
it was about six months ago.
He had me on as a guest when I got punched in the face by that broad oh,
that's right.
I forgot about.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
they rated the FBI,
raided his house,
took him out today and then you get out on to $250,000 bond.
And um,
he wanted credit co,
you know,
to stop contesting what,
what stone said in front of when he testified.
So still say that's not how it went down,
blah,
blah.
So they are fighting and shit and then he's threatening.
Um,
and um,
but uh,
yeah,
I Randy.
So I text Randy today.
I go,
I'm doing Rogan.
I mean,
if you want to walk away,
and he's like,
well,
call me before the show.
Let me know.
He goes,
there's not too much.
I can say right now,
but what's funny is I know both these guys.
That is so weird.
That's so weird.
And he said,
yeah,
let me know.
He goes,
I can't say much because they just arrested the FBI.
They use,
they're going to turn.
They tried to,
I see what Mala is doing.
He's turning Roger Stone against Trump.
Trump is the target.
Yeah.
So he's going to threaten him with,
you know,
he's 60 something years old so he could spend the rest of his life in prison or
talk,
you know,
he's a scary guy.
Mueller,
if he,
if you had a problem and that guy was coming after you,
thank God,
because he's going to do it slow.
Like by the time this actually gets into Trump,
he's going to be,
I don't think they do that slow.
They do.
They start sweating.
They want,
I think that's different than anyway.
I'm very confused.
Time they get to Trump.
He's already so nerve racked.
You know what I'm saying?
Because he liked chips away at his borders like slowly but surely takes away all
the people around him.
Yeah,
he gets closer and you know,
you know,
you know he's concentrating on the family and know.
Oh of course.
Of course.
That's what he does.
And he does that with people like stone.
He'll go after your family and stuff and you notice you never hear a word out of
Ivanka anymore.
No,
exactly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Guarantee you.
Guarantee you they scared the fuck out of her.
But if you want to know about Mandala like you said and how fucking creepy he
is,
he was the head of the FBI during the 80s of the Whitey bulges.
Shit went down and he put four guys in PR.
He listened to this Joe and this,
you can look this up.
This isn't me.
Four guys he put in prison and wrongly it turns out two of them died in prison.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You can go because of Bulger and it had to do with that,
cause.